rebel wilson just shared a throwback
pick from the quote unhealthiest time of
her life and says it's quote never too
late to turn things around yeah it's
exciting on wednesday the 41 year old
actress took to instagram to share this
snap from a past charity tennis
tournament and penned a lengthy caption
recalling that at the time the throwback
photo was taken she was quote overweight
and indulging way too much with junk
food to quote numb her emotions the
pitch perfect star said that her dad
died from a heart attack and it was a
quote sad time quote i didn't think
highly of myself and wasn't valuing
myself how i should have rebel points
out how she's smiling for the picture
and trying to be active quote despite
being in so much pain now the actress
says she is quote proud of what she's
become and achieved writing that she
wants to encourage anyone struggling
with quote weight or body issues or
emotional eating adding quote i feel you
i know what it's like but it's never too
late to start improving yourself and
trying to be the best version of you
possible of course rebel declared 2020
the year of health shortly after she
told et she shed some lbs during four
days of filming cats
i lost eight pounds shooting my number
in four days
one because of yeah there's a lot of
physicality when you see the film but
also they heated up the set
very hot to almost 100 fahrenheit
so that we could never cool down
she documented her workouts and shared
her progress with her fans along the way
dropping a whopping 65 pounds this year
i'm concentrating on health it's a
journey
but no i feel good
back in july she opened up about her
initial motivation to lose weight during
an instagram live
it first started when i was like going
through um looking into fertility stuff
and the doctor was like well you have a
much better chance if you were healthier
and so that's kind of what started that
if i'd you know lost some excess weight
that that it would give give me a better
chance for freezing eggs and having the
eggs be a better quality
um so that's what at first it wasn't
even really myself it was more thinking
of a future
mini me really now she just wants her
followers to know that everyone's
journey to health is their own quote
it's not a race and it's not a
competition it's about respecting
yourself and doing what's best for you
so if you're out there and reading this
today i just wanted to say keep smiling
and keep trying to be active
[Music]
you